do you think about your death  are you afraid of your death yeah sure  absolutely you have to come to terms  with death and that's a tough one for  many people it's it's always there i'm  older than you obviously and i'm getting  closer to it couldn't happen any day  actually  when you get to a certain age you can't  assume that you're going to be alive  tomorrow so i try to deal with that  are you afraid of it  much less so than i was when i was  younger remember i was in vietnam but i  thought i dealt with it there but when i  came back i realized that i wanted to  live  so yes i've learned over time  to get more and more used to it and get  ready for it  what's a good answer to the question of  why live so the realization that you  wanted to live  what was the reason to live  because it was better than being one of  those corpses that i saw in the jungle  uh you know i saw how finite death is  you